Even the most ardent fans of Christmas will
agree – the song “The Twelve Days of Christmas”
does not make a whole lot of sense.
What is a partridge doing in a pear tree?
Partridges are ground-nesting birds!
So where did perhaps the most earworm inducing
Christmas song in history come from, and why
are there twelve days in it, instead of just
one?
To begin with, while most people today only
celebrate one day of Christmas, the holiday
actually is supposed to encompass twelve days
for many religious groups.
While the exact days differ depending on the
sect of Christianity, for most, the holiday
begins on December 25th (Jesus’s birth)
and ends on January 6th, which is known as
the “Epiphany.”
In between there are three feasts to celebrate
the birth of Jesus and the “Incarnation,”
as in the embodiment of God in human flesh.
Hence, the “12 days” of Christmas part
of the song.
Now to the origin of the song itself: For
this, we’re going to start by dispelling
the amazingly popular myth that is touted
by many an otherwise reputable source, despite
a complete lack of evidence supporting the
notion.
To wit, many believe The 12 Days of Christmas
is a Catholic catechism- as in it was written
to help teach Christian values and a better
understanding of religious tenants.
As to why the lyrics are coded, the hypothesis
goes that it was written at a time when Catholics
were legally barred from practicing many aspects
of their religion in Britain and Ireland via
Penal Laws.
So, each seemingly bizarre gift in the song
is supposed to be a code for a particular
symbol in the Catholic faith.
While sources differ slightly on what exactly
the symbols mean, it’s usually stated that
the “true love” is either God or Jesus
Christ; the partridge in the pear tree is
Jesus (however, there are discrepancies on
the interpretations of the particular action
Jesus is supposed to be doing nestled in the
pear tree); the two turtle doves are the old
and new testaments; the French hens are the
theological virtues, faith, hope and charity;
the four calling birds are the four gospels
of Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John (or representing
the individuals themselves); the five golden
rings are the first five books of the Old
Testament; the six geese are the six days
of creation; the seven swans are the seven
sacraments of the Holy Spirit; the milking
maids are the eight blessings in the sermon
on the Mount of Olives; nine ladies are the
Holy Spirit’s nine fruits; ten “Lords
a-leaping” are actually the Ten Commandments;
eleven pipers piping are the eleven apostles;
and, finally, twelve drummers drumming are
the twelve points of belief in the Apostles’
Creed…
Much like the idea that the candy cane was
invented to symbolize Jesus, his purity, and
his blood shed on the cross being complete
fiction (see: The Truth About the Origin of
the Candy Cane), the 12 Days of Christmas
lyrics don’t appear to have any such religious
symbolism, though of course there’s nothing
wrong with creating such symbolism around
existing traditions.
But the subject of this article is the actual
origin of the song, so you’ll forgive us
if we have to dispel the widely touted symbolic
origin story.
As for that, the idea that the 12 Days of
Christmas was a vehicle to secretly teach
Christian tenets seems to have been first
proposed in 1979 by Hugh D. McKellar in a
piece titled, “How to Decode the Twelve
Days of Christmas.”
Much more famously, a few years later Father
Hal Stockert came up with his own version
of the same idea.
When he later repeated this in an article
published online in 1995, the notion spread
like wildfire.
As for how he claims he uncovered the “truth”
about The 12 Days of Christmas, Fr.
Stockert responded to the naysayers, stating,
Over the years since this was written, in
about 1982, and first put out for the online
world to enjoy, I have been deluged every
year with hundreds of “you can’t prove
this!”
kinds of letters.
Obviously, I cannot prove *anything* to anyone
who doesn’t care to believe.
However, for those who ARE interested in the
provenance of the data, and to save myself
the burden of having my inbox filled with
notes asking for evidence to beat debunkers
over the head with, I will simply add this
and leave it to the reader to accept it or
reject it as he or she may choose.
I found this information while I was researching
for an entirely unrelated project which required
me to go to the Latin texts of the sources
pertinent to my research.
Among those primary documents there were letters
from Irish priests, mostly Jesuits, writing
back to the motherhouse at Douai-Rheims, in
France, mentioning this purely as an aside,
and not at all as part of the main content
of the letters.
In those days, even though there are those
who will deny this, too, it was a sufficient
crime between 1538 and nearly 1700 just to
BE a Jesuit in England to find oneself hanged,
drawn and quartered if he fell into the hands
of the authorities…
Whether you believe it or not is irrelevant
to me.
You can enjoy it or not, as you choose.
I hadn’t written it as a doctoral thesis,
simply as some delicious tidbit I thought
the world would be delighted to share over
a holiday season.
It seems, however, that there is more than
one grinch, and I am not at all interested
in feeding the others who remain past the
one in the Christmas cartoons.
Believe if you will.
Dissent if you choose.
Let the rest enjoy the story.
When asked to produce said primary documents
to back up his assertions, he stated, “I
wish I could give them…, but all of my notes
were ruined when our church had a plumbing
leak and the basement flooded…”
The good father would later recant slightly,
noting on an update to his original 1995 webpage
on the subject,
P.S.
It has come to our attention that this tale
is made up of both fact and fiction.
Hopefully it will be accepted in the spirit
it was written.
As an encouragement to people to keep their
faith alive, when it is easy, and when any
outward expressions of their faith could mean
their life…
And, indeed, it turns out, despite extensive
research done on the origins of this song
to find such a connection, there has never
been any documented evidence whatsoever linking
it to such religious symbolism.
Beyond the lack of evidence, this hypothesis
strains credibility on a number of points.
First, nothing in any of that stated symbolism
would have been anything the Catholics couldn’t
have sung or talked about directly under the
aforementioned Penal Laws, as the stated symbolism
doesn’t touch on anything uniquely Catholic-
it’s all stuff the Church of England and
most other Christian denominations have as
part of their core doctrine.
So members of those churches would have been
more than happy to sing a song about such
things directly.
Others try to get around this point by purporting
that it wasn’t a song for Catholics, but
written for all Christians who couldn’t
practice their faith openly.
However, the song is literally titled the
The 12 Days of Christmas and contains mention
of Christmas in the lyrics as a core element
of the song going back to the earliest known
version…
Perhaps not the best choice if one wanted
to avoid letting on your celebration and lyrics
have some connection to Christianity.
And, of course, finding somewhere in the Western
world around the time the song was written
where all sects of Christianity were harshly
banned is something of an effort in futility.
Next up- the lyrics and order of items varied
considerably not just over time but at any
given time.
The most common version most are familiar
with today was put together by composer Frederic
Austin in 1909.
These many variations right from the start
not only results in some of the symbolism
breaking down, but also further illustrates
said symbolism is a modern invention based
on the relatively modern version of the song.
For instance, the “four calling birds”
is supposed to symbolize Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John in some way.
This sort of makes sense, until you learn
that the original lyrics were not “calling
birds” but “collie birds,” which was
just another way to say “blackbirds.”
Other early versions included such things
as “11 bulls a-beating” and “12 bells-a-ringing.”
The “five golden rings” are also not thought
to originally refer to actual rings, but,
in keeping with the theme of bird gift giving,
probably refer to the necks of ring-necked
pheasants.
(If you haven’t picked up on it yet, the
song is essentially just a silly song about
feasting on birds and milk for several days
and then dancing about for fun.)
On top of that, connections between the lyrics
and the supposed symbols they represent are
absurdly tenuous in most cases, meaning if
this song was really meant to teach children
Catholic precepts, as is so often stated,
they must have had a lot of confused kids
on their hands, requiring a lot of explaining
to get the message across, with little hope
said urchins remember what was said the next
year when it was time to sing the song again.
In that sense, the song would much better
serve to teach the children how to count to
twelve than teach religious canon.
So what does the actual hard documented evidence
say about where the song The 12 Days of Christmas
came from?
There are three known French carols that are
exceptionally similar to the Twelve Days of
Christmas and pre-date it by a good margin,
with versions possibly going all the way back
to the 8th century, but this isn’t fully
clear.
Notably, these songs also include giving a
partridge as the first gift given, though
instead of being in a pear tree describes
a “merry little partridge.”
As to how this is thought to connect to the
English version’s nonsensical giving of
a partridge in a pear tree, the Old French
for partridge is “pertriz.”
As for the first known published version of
the English version of the song that has survived
through today, this came about in a 1780 children’s
book called Mirth Without Mischief under the
title “The Twelve Days of Christmas sung
at King Pepin’s Ball.”
In the book, the song does not have any religious
connotation outside of mention of Christmas,
but is explicitly stated to be a song to be
used in a children’s memory-forfeit game.
Essentially, if a child stumbled over a verse,
they were more or less “out,” with the
song not only being difficult due to the number
of items one must keep track of, but, as professor
of classics Edward Phinney, notes, “It’s…
full of tongue-twisters.”
While there are various ways in which these
sorts of memory-forfeit games could be played,
Phinney also notes that in such children’s
games, the singers would often split into
sides of boys and girls with each trading
verses.
When someone got out, they had to kiss someone
on the opposite side or were otherwise made
to pay a trifle penalty.
Illustrating this usage, Thomas Hughes notes
in his 1862 work, The Ashen Faggot: A Tale
for Christmas,
When all the raisins had been extracted and
eaten . . . a cry for forfeits arose.
So the party sat down round Mabel on benches
brought out from under the table, and Mabel
began, ‘The first day of Christmas my true
love sent to me a partridge and a pear tree
. . . And so on.
Each day was taken up and repeated all round;
and for every breakdown (except by little
Maggie, who struggled with desperately earnest
round eyes to follow the rest correctly, but
with very comical results) the player who
made the slip was duly noted down by Mabel
for a forfeit.’
Fast-forward to today and there are literally
hundreds of modern versions of “12 Days
of Christmas”- some more Muppet-y than others-
to go along with the countless variations
sung historically.
While the original versions weren’t meant
to have religious symbolism embedded in them,
they were at least meant to be fun; so no
matter if you are partial to Donny Osmond
or you really love the Rugrats remix, perhaps
we can all agree that we should definitely
re-establish the practice of giving a kiss
when you forget a lyric
of the song.